joining me now for reaction to all this
is former congressman and Fox News
contributor trey Gowdy I served with mr.
Gowdy on the Congress it was a pleasure
to do so and Trey I appreciate you
coming here I still I love the glasses
so it's a good look it's a good I love
you too Jason don't thank you thank you
thank you you've read through the report
you've dealt personally with mr.
director Comey over a series of years
what's your takeaway from what mr.
Horwitz concluded well he's a two-time
offender remember Horowitz also dating
for his handling of the Clinton email
investigation so now he gets dinged in
the other major case he handled in 2016
I never said Comey a would or should go
to jail I'm certainly not going to
apologize to anyone who violated FBI and
Department of Justice policy who
violated an employment agreement who
shared sensitive information about an
ongoing investigation who sent
classified information to an
unauthorized person and then had amnesia
when the FBI came to his home to try to
retrieve government property I'm not
gonna apologize that person I will give
him a piece of unsolicited advice Jason
you referenced Combes obsession with his
higher ethical standing than the rest of
us have so here's my advice you should
aspire to more in life than simply
skating by without having been indicted
if that is your goal in life to just not
meet every essential element of a
criminal offense and you think you
should be congratulated and apologized
to for simply because you were not
indicted you better give back some of
those higher loyalties speaking fees
yeah you know it's really interesting
this little nuance part about when the
FBI did go to his home you know as an
FBI director he does get a skiff a
secured compartmented information
facility but he evidently took this
information didn't keep it in the skiff
he kept it in his own personal as safe
as supposedly and that's a real problem
right I mean just imagine if every
federal employee did that well it's not
a problem if you consider it to be your
own person
no diary so I made it depends on what
the record said did the records say dear
diary Congress was mean to me today but
I did get to talk to the president that
might be a personal diary that's not
what this was he's talking to his boss
he's talking to the head of the
executive branch and then he
memorializes it it's a public record no
matter what he calls it that record
belongs to the United States so he can
call it a diary like birthday cards and
another correspondence but nobody other
than Jim Comey considers that to be
personal do you think there was the
accountability and the consequence you
know the criticism here is that if
somebody else had done this they would
be in handcuffs they would be going to
jail but is Lady Justice being fair and
right here and did he is he being held
accountable
well Jason I'm very sensitive to that
when our fellow citizens think we have a
two-track justice system either for for
the famous or the or the not famous or
the rich of the poor then we're in
trouble as a republic I would tell my
fellow citizens this we have to have
other ways of meeting out accountability
other than simply indictments you know
Hillary Clinton was never indicted she
was never charged therefore never guilty
of a crime but yet the American jury in
2016 meted out a consequence Jim Comey
whether he likes it or not all of his
past in the Southern District of New
York all of his past at main justice all
of his time as an FBI director some of
which I agreed with all of that will be
forgotten the God in history will be all
of our judges but they will judge Jim
Comey based on the fact that he got
dinged on both of the major
investigations he was handling in 2016
by the inspector general that will be
the accountability that's what history
will remember about Jim Comey last good
question for you mr. Comey actually
expects you to apologize you're ready to
apologize tonight what temperature is it
in Hell right now is it is it is it
snowing
when it snows in hell you let me know
why would I apologize to somebody that's
been dinged on both of the major
investigations by a guy like Michael
Horowitz who is hardly a Republican he
was picked by Obama and confirmed by the
Senate I think without a dissenting vote
if that's who said you screwed up Jim
Comey a wasn't a couple of Republican
congressman yeah no a couple of not
really sort of I think you and I were
both on that bandwagon but you're right
Horowitz and impeccable credentials
appointed by Obama confirmed unanimously
by the United States Senate even Comey
praised the Inspector General he's now
been on the receiving end of two
inspector general reports and more to
come - he's a - Tom career offender yeah
three strikes and you're out
that's right well he's out now thank
goodness mr. Gowdy thank you again for
joining us